we're your own personal signature as
jewelry put on your pink donut
sweatshirt and give out some free hugs
because loot is back dress up your cat
with this solar system fascinator after
making him or her work out on this cat
exercise wheel and then foil it's evil
feline plot by reading the book how to
tell if your cat is plotting to kill you
if the cat succeeds at least you'll
finally have a use for this bacon coffin
make breakfast instead of rotting in and
with this blood dripping cutting board
and drink some coffee out of your mug
made in your of China grand illusions is
a great website that sells illusions
like the Einstein hollow face or these
reversing goggles that let you see the
world upside down they also have
magnetic toys like this Han Dynasty
compass and gag gifts like this
ridiculously awesome and dangerous magic
candle for your birthday cake but if
your sweet tooth calls for cookies
instead of cake use this cookie monster
mug so you can have your cookies and
coffee and eat them too or just have
some tea made from a manatee infuser
don't forget to brush your teeth with
some freshly vomited toothpaste then put
on the super cool glow in the dark
sunglasses so you can finally wear them
at night and strap on your USB bracelet
so you don't lose all of your important
information available at get on Hanscom
they come in a variety of colors and
designs if you're a little more old
fashioned try this USB in a bottle to
get your message across or send an
actual letter typed on your vintage
typewriter if you're still bored just
use this book of 642 things to draw
including a beetle a turntable your
least favourite food and a bowl of
pudding or play with some magnetic putty
from vat19.com that's hungry for magnets
prove your constitutional knowledge with
your right to bear arms sure and do some
fashionable reading with these
children's book necklaces including
where the wild things are Harry Potter
and the
if books aren't your thing play with
these retro smartphone cases that let
you play classic ball and maze games on
the back of your phone or go outside and
play with this awesome Starfighter pool
toy if you get hungry from all that
action eat some food off of a cloud
serving tray add a little fridges spiced
with these snow globes salt and pepper
shakers or make it sweeter with unicorn
sprinkles or just do nothing because
today has been cancelled pillow and as
always thanks for watching
I'll get you